what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to nle
choppa
letter to my daughter before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos um
okay so we got
so just so you guys know i haven't i
don't really listen to rap music so
when i react to stuff it's like blind
and i've never heard
like a lot of this type of music before
so it's really interesting to just see
like what i think of it
if drew didn't film it then it ain't
filmed right
[Music]
to my daughter
[Music]
hey
[Music]
baby girl you blessed because i know
some kids in group home ain't seen you
since the week that she was born miss
you with my own
mom beyond some complicated [ __ ] so i
don't see you she put the police on me
at the end of the day it hurt you
kinda hurt me too never let life lessons
break you evaluate the mistake and just
wait
on your breakthrough off you clove i
turned over a new leaf but i get the
type of treatment that belongs to a
[Music]
so it sounds like he was like dating the
mother of his kid
and then she like called the cops on him
and
now he said that i get treated like a
deadbeat so even though he's like trying
to be in the girl
in his daughter's life like she doesn't
let her even though she get real i'm
still praying for your mama
hope you get the chance to see my
grandpa and my grandma cuz they getting
kinda old and grandpa been getting sick
so mariah if you hit this can you please
complete the week please
no pity 4g i know i got a daughter that
i barely get to see it haven't been a
couple hours it's been since the first
week and lately i've been losing sleep
and it's been hard for me to eat
last time i tried to see you went to
jail on that same day
fighting two felonies bout you when i
got another case if i shoot in the house
that you win take my breath away i never
put my hands on the woman wasn't raising
a child
so he's saying that he like tried to go
see
his daughter and she literally like
called the cops on him
even though he like didn't put his hands
on her didn't touch her didn't do
anything
and she's just like able to call the
cops on him
now i'm not overly sure like obviously
there's two sides to every story but
that's actually messed up that like
legally you can do that yes i have
something to live for now i'm dying just
to see you some that i
care for trying to be a cold parent turn
me to a no parent feeling like a
transparent what i tell your grandpa i
cut my feet off just to see your first
steps
bad enough i wasn't in town to see your
first breaths might not hear your first
words and it's hurting me to death every
time i try to do right i get played to
the left never take it for granted [ __ ]
like changing your pound but you nothing
less than the goddess you better not
lower your status a [ __ ] call you
something else but i could wreck his
grandma any question that you got i
promise i got the hounds
another [ __ ] playing a roll that i was
giving the feeling she might be calling
him daddy got me the secret so i'm
tripping if i slid on that boy and got
the blinking yeah i'm tripping gotta
separate my pride from my feelings
oh my gosh that's so sad
oh that's so so he's saying like that
his kids don't even like know who he is
and that like some other guy is raising
no pity 4g
i know i got a daughter that i barely
get to see it haven't been in couple
hours it's been since the first week and
lately i've been losing sleep and it's
been hard for me to eat
i can't really call it pain cause i know
this [ __ ] of process
god give us challenges and see us make
some progress ain't nothing from the
situation i can say i regret wouldn't
even hit a reset learn some life ain't
teaching the wild start to close in this
room getting smaller
laying in this room i'ma design for my
daughter playing this tune that i
designed for the fathers it's good
[ __ ] hearted but distant from they
taller
read books until you go to sleep wake up
cook you something to eat most you to a
baby g
just like your daddy hope that you
remember me cause riley you my mind and
me your momma my words sending me a
friend she forgive a g
trying to put me on top support all the
child needed support would have gave you
more than child support
could ever afford long-term relations
with short-term greed
you know i have like relatives that have
like bad relationships with like the
father or their kids or whatever
but like none of even though a lot of
them are like girls they would never
keep the father away like from their
kids like that's so messed up
be careful what you pick when you're the
one that's in need such a big miracle
such a little girl never let them break
your spirit
[Music]
[Music]
your curl
please no pity 4g i know i got a
daughter that i barely get to see
it haven't been a couple hours it's been
since the first week and lately i've
been losing sleep and it's been hard for
me to eat
please no pity 4g i know i got a
daughter that i barely get to see it
haven't been a couple hours it's been
since the first week and lately i've
been losing sleep and it's been hard for
me
[Music]
i made this song for the fathers that go
through the struggle of being kept from
their child and even the mothers
who are going through the same struggle
keep that head high guys
god got us in the long run the marathon
must continue love you
it's like the message at the end
this video was dedicated to my grandma
who recently passed away and didn't get
the chance to meet her granddaughter
that's actually so sad um that's like a
storyline that you don't at least i
haven't really heard much you kind of
hear
always like the dad that like doesn't
want to be around and you don't hear as
much about like
the mom that actually isn't letting a
like a dad see the kids so that was
one of my favorite songs i think that
i've probably reacted to i would give
that song a five out of five it was
really like
touching and i thought it was really
like well written you could tell
it's like a story from like the
beginning to the end i didn't have any
questions about like what it was about
um but let me know in the comments if
you guys agree or you disagree with me
let me know what song i should react to
next time and as usual do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and run that
ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos i'll talk to you guys
next time